bonjour monsieur dérange pas et
justement je les portais faire des
courses je suis l'inspecteur chercher de
votre enquête sur mon blog vous avez
désigné monsieur loin ici ou et la
compote et la purée
sonia porot mardi puis tu fais j'en ai
pas prendre dans cette salle et où elle
se croit où ça va c'est l'habitude ou
quoi piquer ici et elles mêmes qui se
font voler leur temps tiers
si vous avez des questions sinon on va
très bien si on avait que des petits
vieux comme dans ses remises par très
bien faire des petits jeux et quoi ça a
l'air bon là d'autres des conneries
comme ça me dérange pas je suis là j'ai
planqué les cigarettes a qu'un qui
briquet dans une boîte de vitesses
c'est comment tu veux que jerry moyes la
chercher la nana la boîte de vitamines
bonjour monsieur je connais je m'appelle
charisme la france ne répondait pas je
sais que ça va mal a dit préparez vous
pour lui me touche pas c'est un dingue
on respire on est jeudi en forme parce
que j'ai fait choix en fin de journée
merci rapporté t elle s'arrêter comme
moi tu arrêter arrêter d'attendre
mais je me suis c'est moi qui vous ai
repêchés mais ils sont de la ville ce
qui paraît en mon nom
vous ressemblez à mon père j'ai pas
comment l'expliquer j'ai besoin de
l'histoire un voyant d'honneur même page
de ouvert je te donne dix minutes doit
être cool
anne veut à l'attack bon établissement
quelle formule à quoi